bonjour alors vous confiez parmi les
gens la liberté lors de cet entretien
Bonjour Samantha oui effectivement c'est
un gars la voix off à donner une tant
mieux à toutes les rédactions de la
famille de RT en allemand en anglais en
espagnol en arabe et évidemment en
français international aborder surtout
les questions concernant les relations
avec les États-Unis ainsi que les
tensions avec le temps et RT un Allemand
la toute nouvelle chaîne dans la famille
2rt qui a commencé sa diffusion
seulement le 16 décembre poser les
questions concernant la dégradation de
la relation bilatérale et la censure
dans rt2 qui fait actuellement l'objet
la réaction de hier tu es un arabe
s'intéresser surtout au dossier
nucléaire iranien est la situation en
Syrie et la rédaction de RTL en espagnol
à poser une question au sujet de
l'Amérique latine mais la façon dont la
Russie notamment les élections aussi et
on Duras quand tu allais rédaction en
français notre rédaction nous avons posé
une question au sujet de d'une
déclaration du ministre français des
Affaires étrangères Jean-Yves Le Drian
qui a promis de graves conséquences à la
Russie en cas d'invasion en Ukraine
voici la réponse du ministre russe
le président russe pendant ces dernières
semaines ainsi que d'autres représentant
des autorités russe en plusieurs fois le
sujet de soi-disant escalade pour
laquelle on ne menace de punir
maintenant de côté nous avons déjà donné
des explications sur les actions de
notre fournisseur mais ce qu'ils font
sur notre propre territoire c'est la
même histoire avec les Français les
Britanniques leur posant des questions
mais la réponse 90 entend rien
sauf les menaces
permanente à mon avis au lieu de menaces
partenaire Occident te ferait mieux de
se concentrer sur les obligations direct
la France et l'Allemagne
dois faire qui est vrai specters les
accords de Minsk de
[Musique]
accusant la Russie de d'une d'une
escalade de connexion de t'en basse
part de basse ou de l'Ukraine
entière de
la part de l'exécutif et la majorité
présidentielle qui refuse régulièrement
d'ailleurs depuis le lancement et
jusqu'à ce jour à d'accréditer nos
journaliste écouter
mots suivants deux prêts
tout ce qui
travaille à l'étranger
compte tenu de se fait de discrimination
par exemple RT n'a pas d'accréditation
boutique n'as pas des creditation auprès
de l'Élysée le président lors de sa
conversation téléphonique avec Monsieur
Macron à attirer l'attention sur ce qui
met son son espoir que le collègue
français fasse tout pour que les médias
russes y compris RP travail en France et
que le travail soit aussi confortable
que le travail de Lord homologue de
leurs collègues en Russie
et ce principe elle appliquées ASSP en
Allemagne et autres russe et qui sont
confrontés à sa destination à l'étranger
le ministre des Affaires étrangères 5
elle a pas pris la parole dans un
contexte international marqué par un
regain des tensions entre les États-Unis
l'heure d'aller d'une part et elle a
réussi d'autre part la diplomatie
dernier jour des propositions de
garantie de sécurité mutuelle qui
pourrait déboucher sur un dialogue avec
Washington prochainement merci beaucoup
à vous avez mal pour toutes ces
précisions en direct depuis Moscou